[Music]
on this Sunday night the three-year
fight for justice
on the anniversary Canadians remember
those killed on flight PS 752 we're here
to seek Justice for the victims and
their families why victims families feel
the government hasn't gone far enough
with Iran
already battered by flooding this is way
off the charts California braces for a
parade of cyclones
goodbye meetings the Canadian Tech Giant
canceling its employees calendars and
how an NFL players terrifying Health
scare United the U.S
[Applause]
Farah Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
years ago today a passenger jet PS 752
Bound for Canada was shot down by Iran's
revolutionary guard for loved ones some
who lost their entire immediate family
in that moment it's felt more like a
lifetime fighting for justice memorials
took place across Canada today there
were 176 people on board among them 55
Canadians and 30 permanent residents in
Toronto today each of the photos of the
casualties were named in a video tribute
and across the country similar scenes
played out globalist Sharia israe spoke
to some of the relatives who say they're
frustrated by the inaction of the
Canadian and Iranian governments and are
using today's anniversary to push the
government to act
for the families of the victims no
amount of time can fill the crushing
void
[Music]
feel emptiness Shaheen moghadam has felt
that emptiness for exactly three years
on January 8 2020 he lost his wife
shakiba and their nine-year-old son
rostine when Iran's Islamic
revolutionary guard shot down flight
ps752 I cannot sleep every every night
I tell you every 20 minutes maybe
sometimes every one hour I'm waking up
because I hear they're calling me they
were among the 176 people who died that
day most with ties to Canada
across the country people gathered on
the third anniversary to honor the
children wives and husbands Left Behind
the person I was it to me looks like a
different lifetime ago I mean it was
someone else prime minister Justin
Trudeau attended the largest Memorial in
Toronto we are all working together at
this Federal level to hold the Iranian
regime accountable Canada formally
triggered a process last month to try to
hold Iran accountable through binding
arbitration if the regime refuses to
take part the case could make its way to
the international court of justice it's
taken so long for us to get anywhere
close to Justice cave charuce is giving
legal advice to families and believes
the 2020 down and Iran's recent deadly
Crackdown on anti-government protests
are intertwined people are demanding
Justice for a lot of the victims of
Iran's regime for the past 40 years
including those that perished on the
flights the hope is Canada will put more
pressure on Iran list the entirety of
the nefarious Islamic revolutionary
guard Corps as a terrorist organization
they want the RCMP to open a criminal
investigation and for Ottawa to fight
harder for compensation something
moghadam doubts he'll ever see the
problem is our government they are they
don't let us to go after Justice
searching for a shred of Justice after
so much loss teria isri Global News
Ottawa
turning now to some breaking news almost
exactly two years to the day of the
January 6 attack on the U.S Capitol a
similar scene is playing out in Brazil
thousands of supporters of the country's
former president jair bolsonaro broke
through a barricade and stormed the
Congress building in the capital
protesters climbed on roofs and smashed
windows before making their way inside
video shows broken desks and chairs
outside they were met with tear gas from
police several people were taken into
custody many of the protesters dispute
the results of the October 30th election
which saw Lula de Silva beat bolsonaro
the former president has repeatedly
questioned The credibility of the
election de Silva was sworn in as
president a week ago and he's not
currently in the capital and says
everyone involved in today's protest
will be found and will be punished
to the war in Ukraine now Russia says it
struck a major blow against Ukrainian
forces with missile strikes on Sunday
but the damage they claim to have dealt
is being contested
Russia's defense minister claims their
missiles targeted two bases in the
Eastern donesque region then killed over
600 Ukrainian troops in retaliation for
Ukrainian Strike last week that killed
dozens of Russian soldiers but Ukrainian
officials deny moscow's latest claims
they say despite the missiles damaging
some civilian buildings there were no
signs of any casualties whatsoever
California is in the grip of a series of
dangerous storms after a week of deadly
weather some parts of the state saw
Heavy Rain leading to widespread
flooding and landslides While others
were buried in snow Millions have been
affected and it's not over yet with an
intense atmospheric River taking aim
Jennifer Johnson has the latest
hundreds of roads look like Rivers high
winds of torn down structures Rivers up
and down California are hitting record
levels as residents are pelted with
storm after storm I could hear the rain
hitting everything and I could hear
things bouncing around my porch
First Responders have had to save
several people from quickly Rising flood
waters including this one in Sacramento
where two people were rescued the storm
has caused several deaths including a
two-year-old child killed by a falling
tree when I first arrived on seeing a
frantic father came out of the
householding the child
peers have been destroyed in several
coastal towns hundreds of thousands of
homes have been flooded or without power
forcing many to live in area shelters
folks come to us on sometimes the worst
days of their lives even if you don't
choose to stay the night if you've got a
friend or family that you're staying
with you can still come to the shelter
grab a hot meal the so-called
atmospheric River coming from the
Pacific Ocean has caused the torrential
rains and high winds some Northern
California ski slopes have had to shut
down as chair lifts are tossed around
many neighborhoods are shut off by
Fallen trees blocking roads this is way
off the charts I mean cumulatively what
we experienced in the last week is
cumulatively more than I can say we've
experienced in 15 years crews are also
working around the clock to cover breaks
and hillsides with tarps to stop more
landslides on terrain already weakened
by drought and wildfires another worry
for homeowners who fear they'll soon
have to evacuate I've been working on
for quite a few days because in 20 mile
an hour it's hard to get it down oh God
everything's destroyed and now
forecasters are warning another
atmospheric River of moisture will hit
California Monday bringing what they
call a Relentless parade of cyclones
over the next few days more dangerous
weather for a state that has already had
enough
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
meanwhile Australia is experiencing
what's being called a one in a 100 year
flood event
large swaths at the region the size of
California in fact are in the Northwest
part of the country and they're
underwater many roads are impassable and
several communities are now completely
isolated supplies have had to be flown
in hundreds of people have been forced
from their homes and there are concerns
about the number of livestock lost and
the impact that's going to have on the
area
the flooding was sparked last week by
severe weather a system called Ellie a
former tropical Cyclone that brought
with it heavy rain
there is shock and outrage in Virginia
where a grade one teacher was shot by a
six-year-old student
it happened in a classroom on Friday
after what officials are calling an
altercation and police do not believe
the shooting was accidental the teacher
was critically injured but has since
improved and is currently listed as
being in stable condition no other
students were hurt it's still unclear
how the child got access to the gun the
mayor of the city where this happened is
now calling the shooting a red flag for
the entire country
pressure is growing on the Quebec
government to hold a public inquiry into
the death of an illegally detained
inmate 21-year-old Nika St Andre spring
died inside a Montreal prison during an
altercation with guards on December 24th
a day after he was supposed to be
released now Advocates are demanding The
Province take a hard look at systemic
racism and the role it could have played
Dan Spector has more
a young black man lost his life because
of clerical flaws and poor judgment two
weeks after the death of Nicos DeAndre
spring Lobby group the red Coalition
holds a press conference demanding the
government do more to shine light on
what happened the group's director
claiming the prison guards the young
aspiring artist clash with were rookies
on the job the use of
the pepper spray spit guard and then the
water it acted like like a water board
so he was suffocating spring was being
detained at Bordeaux prison in Montreal
as he faced multiple charges including
assaulting a peace officer criminal
harassment and possessing a weapon for a
dangerous purpose he pleaded not guilty
and was already released on December
23rd but for some reason he was still
behind bars the next day that's when an
altercation with guards took place
leading to Spring's death we would be
filing a systemic discrimination
complaint systemic discrimination
complaint
with the Quebec Ombudsman a manager and
a prison guard have been suspended and
multiple investigations are already
underway including a Provincial Police
criminal investigation that could lead
to charges against prison staff and a
coroners in quest the red Coalition
wants the coroner's inquiry to be made
public any public inquiry should not
just be looking at the individual case
although that's the point of departure
but looking at the structural systemic
problems that facilitated it the Lego
government has repeatedly denied the
existence of systemic racism in the
province and Advocates want structural
issues scrutinized we can't have that
conversation when there's actually a
blanket denial that the systemic racism
actually exists the Coalition is also
demanding video footage of the incident
be released immediately and that an
independent autopsy is completed saying
the black community has no faith in
government institutions it's question of
trust really the public security
Ministry said in a statement it wants to
shine a light on the events surrounding
Spring's death including the illegal
detention a public inquiry has not been
excluded but the criminal investor
education needs to be completed first
the mistakes made will need to be
answered for the inspector Global News
Montreal
still had a look at Pope Benedict XVI 's
fell resting place opens to the
and what could lead to increased
political instability in this country
the warning from an american-based
research group that's next
an influential us-based research group
is warning that Canada is at heightened
risk of polarization and political
dysfunction and the group indicates
several factors including challenging
economic conditions and a declining
Trust In traditional media could
contribute David Aiken explains
last year's trucker Convoy was only the
most visible symptom of a Canadian
Society becoming increasingly polarized
now Eurasia group a new york-based
consultancy is warning its clients that
the forces that spawn the protests are
likely to continue and intensifying
Canada in 2023 and who are eurasia's
clients well some of the world's biggest
Pension funds and other institutional
investors who need to manage risk it is
worth watching because from an
Investor's perspective if it's very
difficult to tackle big issues like
climate change because of a deepening
and widening moat between roughly
speaking progressives and conservatives
in in the country then it's a more it's
a dicier prospect for investment
the risks to Global Peace and security
are almost self-evident Russia's war in
Ukraine an aggressive China and a
defense of Iran that may feel backed
into a corner
meanwhile the world citizens are also
grappling with inflation and could be
dealing with a possible energy Crunch
and what Eurasia group calls Global
Water stress Eurasia groups Gerald butts
the former principal secretary to prime
minister Trudeau explains we see highly
heavily densely populated areas not just
in the places where we westerners would
normally consign those problems to and
Coastal East Africa for instance
equatorial Asia but you look at what's
happening in the Western United States
and indeed in western Canada we've had a
mega drought of historically
unprecedented proportions
Canada is vulnerable to all of those
risks but Eurasia group is also sound in
the alarm about declining Trust In
traditional media combined with the
country's exposure to a hyper-partisan
U.S media environment I think the the
biggest
problem that it generates though is that
there's no agreed upon set of facts now
all its factors underline the importance
and value of the country's political
leaders Federal and provincial right or
left to reach cross-partisan solutions
to manage the risks in what is likely to
be a turbulent 2023 Farah
David Akin and Ottawa thank you David
the tomb of Pope Benedict XVI has opened
to the public in Vatican City his final
resting place is the Crypt under Saint
Peter's Basilica he was buried there on
Thursday after his funeral Pope Benedict
died on December 31st ending a decade of
the former and current pope living side
by side in the Vatican he was the first
pope in 600 years to resign
[Music]
ahead clearing out corporate calendars a
bold experiment by a Canadian company
why Shopify is saying no to meetings we
discuss the pros and any potential cons
next
[Music]
foreign
the holidays are coming to a close and
many Canadians are heading back to work
and if you work in corporate Canada
chances are lots of meetings will fill
up your schedule once again but last
week employees of e-commerce giant
Shopify went into their calendars to
find any long-standing or large meeting
was canceled in one swoop Shopify
estimates it scrapped 10 000 events from
corporate calendars it's part of a bold
experiment from the Ottawa based company
to increase productivity joining us now
from Toronto is Farhan Tower he is the
vice president of engineering at Shopify
and part of the team running this move
Ron thanks for joining us first of all
how exactly does this work are you
talking about all meetings
Yeah so basically what we did was we
removed all recurring meetings with more
than two people and then we also
implemented this our reaffirmed our
strategy around no meeting Wednesday so
we just deleted everything from the
calendar for folks
and what was the reaction to that
well it's not the first time we've done
experiments like this but the idea is
kind of new year new resolutions to you
know leave slack groups you're no longer
participating in and clean the calendars
I think that at the beginning folks are
surprised right to see an empty calendar
coming into the new year but again
subtraction is harder than addition
right it's easy to add things and so we
wanted to have a two-week moratorium as
well to not re-add those meetings so you
can really figure out what's important
I think a lot of people watching uh
think that oh this is a great idea I
wish my company would do this but there
are a lot of questions I mean how does
it measure productivity how does
brainstorming work you know how do you
convey a complex problem to a larger
group of people what is the nitty-gritty
or how does it work yeah so what we're
trying to do is really just give some
parameters and Frameworks for folks so
for example you can have large meetings
they just have to happen on Thursday
between 11 and 5 PM so it's really this
idea that you can't overwhelm folks with
meetings after meetings and then they
have to do their individual contributor
time at night instead we want to focus
on the makers the builders and allow
them to actually do their work and have
meetings be the sparingly thing that
happens only once in a while
so is it is it a move to get people to
just call each other on the phone and if
they need something instead of
scheduling a whole meeting is that the
point so you can still do like
one-to-one meetings the idea was just
that meetings are this thing that are
easy to again add or easy to do and hard
to say no to hard to decline and so we
wanted to make it easier for folks to
actually just get all this crud off
their calendar and so we made it we just
did it for them and now folks can over
the next two weeks really figure out
what's important and add those things
back in if they provide value are you
concerned about isolation I mean there's
those few minutes at the beginning of a
meeting where people Chit Chat uh are
you worried about that
well so we still have lots of things
that we do to make sure folks are
connected to the company right we have
asynchronous and synchronous tools for
folks to communicate we're still going
to have meetings we're still probably
going to have reoccurring meetings we
just wanted to start the new year with a
way for folks to kind of reset and
figure out what's really going to help
them build things for our merchants
do you think this could work in other
sectors as well
100 I think uh you know the Outreach
I've gotten from folks who said how did
you do this are you going to open source
the tools they're very excited about
actually helping employees focus on what
matters
okay for hunt hour vice president of
engineering at Shopify thanks for your
time
thanks
United for Demar Hanlon next the
heartwarming tributes to an NFL player
on the mend
[Music]
and it has been a dramatic week for the
National Football League last Monday
Buffalo Bills player Demar Hamlin
collapsed on the field and nearly died
from a cardiac arrest but now he is
recovering in hospital and is in
especially High Spirits as players
coaches and fans continue to pay tribute
to him and as Ross Lord reports the
heartwarming support from his team
remains strong as they kicked off
today's game
as they took the field for the first
time since in your tragedy the Buffalo
Bills wore the number three on their
uniforms a tribute to Demar Hamlin whose
terrifying Cardiac Arrest last Monday
put a stop to a game and had his
teammates fearing the worst please rise
and show yourself
[Applause]
before the game Hamlin posted online
nothing I want more than to be running
out that tunnel with my brothers God
using me in a different way today he
added a picture of himself in his
hospital bed another positive
development for a 24 year old known for
expressing love and support to others we
can't wait to see you get better and
when you're back it's going to be a huge
celebration we love you and this one's
for you today baby let's go buffalo on
the opening kickoff came a stunning
development the result an absolute
contrast to the last time they were on
the field Hamlin's doctors say he'd
likely have died if not for immediate
CPR and the use of a defibrillator on
him while on the field in hospital
Hamlin communicated at first in writing
asking doctors a question yes
Yes Man the answer is yes
Hamlin's breathing tube has since been
removed doctors say he's recovering
remarkably well and is able to speak to
his family and his care team in another
online post Hamlin said he's thankful to
everyone who's reached out and prayed
this will make me stronger on the road
to recovery Hamlin's brush with death
has some football analysts suggesting
fans should rethink their obsession with
a dangerous game
but in a country where political
partisanship has created deep divisions
Hamlin's ordeal has also brought people
together for common cause
Ross Lord Global News
and that's global national for the
Sunday nights I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your Canada is the
Rainy Streets of downtown Vancouver we
love seeing your Canada so please keep
emailing us those photos to viewers at
globalnational.com Donna will be back
with you tomorrow until next time take
care of yourselves and each other good
night
foreign